[MUSIC PLAYING]
NIKITA NAMJOSHI: Hi, everyone.
Welcome to Faster ML Model
Training and Experimentation
with Vertex AI.
I'm Nikita.
I'm a Google Cloud
developer advocate,
and today I'm going
to show you how
to use Vertex AI for
hyperparameter tuning
and distributed training.
Vertex AI is Google
Cloud's managed machine
learning platform, and by
the end of this session,
you'll know how to use the
Vertex AI managed training
service to train a TensorFlow
model using distributed
training and how to
launch multiple trials
of your training code for
automated hyperparameter
tuning.
Now, while we'll be using
TensorFlow for today's example,
the concepts are applicable
to other machine learning
frameworks as well, so you could
also run hyperparameter tuning
on Vertex AI with PyTorch,
XGBoost, et cetera.
Now, before we get
into how to do this,
I want to spend a minute
talking about why we want
to do this in the first place.
The values you select for
your model's hyperparameters
can make all the difference.
If you're only trying to tune
a handful of hyperparameters,
you might be able to run
experiments manually.
However, with deep
learning models
where you're often
juggling hyperparameters
for the architecture, the
optimizer, the batch size,
the learning rate, automating
these experiments at scale
quickly becomes a necessity.
And it's not just about
tracking the results
from all of these experiments.
You also want a way
to efficiently search
the space of possible
values so you
don't waste as much time
trying out combinations
that yield low-accuracy scores.
But training a model
once takes long enough,
so having to run multiple trials
of your training code, each
with different values, can
be very time-consuming.
So we're going to leverage
Vertex AI for two key things.
The first is a serverless
hyperparameter tuning service
which will help us to both
track the values from our trials
and intelligently select
the values to try out.
The second is a multi-GPU setup
to make our model train faster
because faster model training
makes for faster iteration
to reach your modeling goals.
If you'd like to follow
along, all of the steps
are documented in
this codelab, so
feel free to follow along
or just watch and then refer
to the lab after the session.
Let's jump in.
If you open up the
codelab link, you
will see something
that looks like this.
And we can click over
to section 2, which
is the intro to Vertex AI.
So as I mentioned
earlier, Vertex AI
is Google Cloud's managed
machine learning platform.
There are a lot of
different products
and you can see them down
here in this diagram.
And you can use these products
together or with other GCP
or open-source tools.
And today we'll just be focusing
on two of these products--
Training and Workbench.
Training is the serverless
training product within Vertex,
and Workbench is the
managed JupyterLab
solution within Vertex.
So we'll click Next
and section 3 just
provides a little
bit of information
on the actual use
case for today.
We'll be using
hyperparameter tuning
to help us to discover optimal
parameters for an image
classification model that will
train on the horses or humans
data set.
So we can click
on this data set--
this is pulled from
TensorFlow data sets--
and we can take a look.
And as you might imagine,
as the name implies,
this data set has images
of horses and humans.
So we'll be building
an image classification
model that tries to
identify whether an image is
of a horse or a human.
So there are kind
of two key concepts
we'll be working with today.
The first is
hyperparameter tuning.
And the way that hyperparameter
tuning works in Vertex AI
is that Vertex AI will run
multiple trials of the training
application using values
for our hyperparameters
set within limits
that we specify.
And Vertex AI will keep
track of the results of each
of these trials and
make adjustments
for subsequent trials.
So I think the easiest
way to understand
this is just to take a
look at the end state.
So we can click over here,
and this is the Google Cloud
Console, and this is what
will be kind of working up to
by the end of this codelab.
But you can see, down
here, the accuracy scores
for each of our trials.
So I'm going to go
ahead and sort this.
And these are all of
the different trials
that we ran of our
hyperparameter tuning job.
And on each trial, we
tried out different values
for the learning
rate, the momentum,
and the number of units
in the last hidden layer.
So these trials were run,
and each time, Vertex AI
recorded the accuracy metric.
And we sorted these,
and as a result,
we can see that the trial that
had the highest accuracy value
was this trial ID number 5.
And so that means that
these are the values
we would want to set for our
learning rate, the momentum,
and the number of units.
So this gives you
just a little picture
of what we'll be working up to.
So back in the lab,
the second component
that is important to this
hyperparameter and distributed
training job is using
the tf.distribute module.
So if you have a
single GPU, TensorFlow
will use this GPU to
speed up model training
without any extra
work on your part,
but if you want to get an
additional boost by using
multiple GPUs, you'll
need to use a strategy
from the tf.distribute module.
This is a module that helps
you to run computation
across multiple devices.
And today we'll be using
the MirroredStrategy,
which is the simplest
strategy to get started with.
It allows you to train a
model across multiple GPUs
within a single machine.
So there is a little bit of
detail added in this lab here
to explain kind of what
MirroredStrategy is doing,
but honestly you don't
really need to the details
in order to use it in your
code and get the benefit.
So I'm going to skip over
that, but I did link to a video
that I recorded that goes a
lot deeper into how distributed
training works in TensorFlow
and a little bit of the theory.
So if you're curious,
feel free to check out
this video linked here.
Now, today we're going to
use both distributed training
and hyperparameter tuning,
but note that, with Vertex AI,
you can use a hyperparameter
tuning job without distributed
training and you can also
do a distributed training
without hyperparameter
tuning and just train a model
with multiple devices.
But today we're going
to see how to use both.
So with that, we are ready
to jump into the lab.
So I'm in the Google
Cloud Console,
and I'm in a project where
I have billing enabled.
So in order to run
this, you'll need
to make sure that your
project does have a billing
account associated with it.
And I'm currently in
the Vertex AI section.
I got there by clicking
on the Navigation menu,
and I've actually pinned
Vertex the AI to the top here.
But if you don't have
it pinned, you'll
just need to scroll all the
way down to the Artificial
Intelligence
section, right here,
and you can select Vertex AI.
So before you get
started, you will
need to set up a
couple different APIs.
You'll need to make sure that
you have the Container Registry
API enabled as well as the
Compute Engine API enabled.
And I've gone ahead
and done that already,
just because it takes
a couple of minutes,
but if you need to still do
that, be sure to check out
step 4 in the codelab,
which will show you how
to enable both of these APIs.
Additionally, if you've never
used Vertex AI in your project
before, you will be prompted
here on this home page
to enable the API, so be
sure to click that button
and make sure it's enabled.
And once that's done, you can
click over here on the left
to where it says Workbench.
And Workbench is GCP's
managed notebook solution.
So we'll click on Managed
Notebooks up here at the top,
and you can see a couple
of existing notebooks
that I already have.
If you have not used Workbench
in your project before,
you will be prompted here
to enable the notebooks
API as well.
So just make sure
that you do that.
So the next step is to
create a new notebook.
We'll click up here where
it says New Notebook.
And the first thing we'll do
is give our notebook a name.
And then, under
Advanced Settings,
we can set the idle
shutdown time to 60 minutes.
So this is just how
long the notebook
will run before it'll shut
down due to inactivity.
This is really important just
because, if you're like me
and you forget to shut
down your notebook
when you're done using
it, you won't be charged
and that's great.
This just means it's going to
shut the notebook down when
you're not using it anymore.
And so I just set
this to 60 minutes.
The next thing you'll want to
do is click this Enable Terminal
option.
And then we can select Create.
And this will take about a
minute or so to be created,
but once this instance
has been provisioned,
we will see the open
JupyterLab text turn blue
and we'll be able to open up
our instance and authenticate.
Once the text turns blue, you
can select Open JupyterLab.
And you will need to
authenticate the very first
time that you use the instance.
So you can just follow
the steps in the UI
to get the authentication code.
Paste the code,
select Authenticate,
and we will be in our
managed JupyterLab instance.
So that completes the setup.
And now we can get into
preparing our training code.
So from the Launcher menu,
I will select on Terminal.
And this will open up a
new terminal instance.
And from the lab, we
can copy and paste
the following commands, which
will create a directory called
vertex-codelab, and then we
can CD into that directory.
And you'll see that directory
show up right over here
on the left.
The next commands
we'll want to run
is to make a directory
called trainer
within that codelab
directory, and then,
within the trainer
directory, we'll
create a file called task.py.
So let's take a look.
We've got Vertex codelab.
Within that, we've got
this trainer directory,
and within that, we've got
this file called task.py.
So I'm going to open
up this task.py file.
And this is where we will paste
in all of our training code.
And this code will contain
all of the important steps
we need to download the
data, preprocess the data,
create the model,
and train the model.
But note that for a more
production application, a more
realistic application,
you'll likely
have multiple files within
this trainer directory,
and not just a single file.
You'll probably
have a data.py file
which handles all the
data preprocessing,
maybe a model.py file where
you create the actual model,
some UDLs to help
any helper functions
and import those within your
main training task.py file.
But for this simple
example, I've
just included one Python script
under the trainer directory
that has all of the code we'll
need to run a training job.
So I'm going to copy and paste
in the code from the codelab.
OK, so here we have the code.
And let's quickly walk through
what's going on in this file.
So at the top
here, we start just
by importing the
libraries that we need.
And then we set a
couple of variables.
This function,
called get_args is
what is going to use argparse
to parse our command line
arguments.
And this is where
we will include
all of the hyperparameters
that we want to tune.
I'll dive a little
bit deeper into this
in just a minute when
we talk about how
to use the hyperparameter
tuning service.
This next function,
preprocess_data,
just preprocesses our data by
resizing it and also scaling
it.
And then we have a
create_dataset function
which is going to load in the
data from TensorFlow data sets
and then create a training data
set and a validation data set.
So that's what it returns.
These data sets have
been preprocessed,
they've been shuffled,
and they've been batched.
The create_model function will
define and compile our model.
And this is using the Keras
functional API to do so.
If you're not very familiar
with TensorFlow in Keras,
don't worry too much about it.
This function is really just
here to create the model.
And whatever framework
you're using,
just think about that
in context of how
you would create a model in
that particular framework.
Now the main function is, of
course, where most of the stuff
is happening.
So the first thing we do
here is we get our args
and we then create our
distribution strategy.
So again, there are kind
of two high-level concepts
we're working with here--
distributed training and
hyperparameter tuning.
So in order to do
distributed training,
the first thing you need to
do is define our distribution
strategy.
And as I mentioned earlier,
we are using the TensorFlow
MirroredStrategy.
So we define that
right over here.
The next step is to scale
our batch size by the number
of GPUs that we have.
So that's what's happening
in this line right over here.
Instead of setting the
number of GPUs to two
and just hardcoding
it right here,
I went ahead and used this
num_replicas_in_sync method,
which will just return
the number of GPUs
that we have on our machine.
So that's going to be two
when we launch our training
job because we're going
to make use of two GPUs,
but this just saves us
from having to hardcode
that number in here.
And the reason we
scale the batch size
is now, because we have two
GPUs or we have multiple GPUs,
we want to make sure that
we're using every GPU
to its maximum potential.
So scaling up the batch
size is a best practice
when you use the
MirroredStrategy
from the tf.distribute module.
And again, if you'd like
to learn a little bit more
about why that is the
case, be sure to check out
the video which I have
linked in the Training Code
section of the codelab as well.
And then the last step
you'll need for tf.distribute
is to wrap the creation
of your model variables
within the scope
of the strategy.
So that's what's
happening in line 89.
We call with
strategy.scope, and then we
call the create_model function.
And again, the
create_model function
is what creates the model
and also compiles it.
So that's where all of our
model variables get created.
And that's all you need
to do in order to make
use of distributed training.
This now means that, when
our model training kicks off,
it will be able to use multiple
GPUs in order to train faster.
So the next important
things we need to do
are make sure that our code is
prepared to do hyperparameter
training with Vertex AI.
So the first thing
that you'll want to do
is, all the way up at the top
where we import the Hypertune
library.
So this library
here basically helps
us to report the metrics that
we care about to Vertex AI.
And recall, earlier,
I showed you
what that end state looks like
where we have multiple training
trials and we were
recording the accuracy
of those different trials.
This Hypertune library is
what's going to help us do that.
So after you've imported
the Hypertune library,
the next thing you need to do is
create this get_args function.
And you'll use
argparse to define
all of the hyperparameters
that you want to tune.
So in this case, we have
chosen to tune the learning
rate, the momentum,
and the number of units
in the last hidden layer.
And these are just
three hyperparameters
that I chose to tune, but feel
free to experiment with others
or add more, change these
out, whatever you're
curious to experiment with.
Something to note is that you
can call these hyperparameters
whatever you like.
I chose learning rate,
momentum, num_units.
These string values
are up to you
to decide just need to make
sure that you are consistent
everywhere.
When you launch the job,
you'll want to refer back
to these strings as well.
So just make sure
you're consistent,
but otherwise you can call
them whatever you like.
Now, the next thing
we'll need to do in order
to use the hyperparameter
tuning service
is to define our metric.
So that's what's happening
over here and line 96.
It's important that we have
a metric that we are tracking
because we want to
know how effective
each trial of our
hyperparameter tuning job--
how effective each trial was.
If we just were to
run multiple trials
but not be tracking
a metric, we would
have no idea which trial
was the most performant.
So in this case, I've decided
that validation accuracy is
the metric that I want to
track, but it might be different
for, of course, the regression
problem or maybe a problem
with class imbalance.
Whatever metric it
is that you think
is relevant to your problem,
you'll want to define that.
And then I've defined that
as this HP metric right here.
Now, this might look
a little strange,
but this is just something
that's particular to Keras.
When you use model.fit in
Keras, as we have here,
it will return this
history object.
And the history.history
attribute
is a record of the training
loss values and metric values
at successive epochs.
So when we compiled
the model, we
passed in this accuracy
metric right here.
And that just means that our
history.history attribute
is going to keep a
record of both the loss
as well as the accuracy
for our training
and our validation data
sets on each epoch.
So here I'm just extracting
out the validation accuracy key
and I'm pulling the last
value from that list
because we want the last
epoch's accuracy measure.
If you're using a different
framework such as Scikit-learn.
And I think Scikit-learn has
that accuracy score function.
So that's really what
you would use here.
This is just your calculation of
the metric that you care about.
And once you have defined
and calculated that metric--
and again, in this case, we're
interested in the validation
accuracy--
we will go ahead and create
an instance of Hypertune
using this Hypertune library.
And then we will pass
in a tag for our metric.
We're going to call it accuracy.
And then we will also pass
in the actual metric value,
which we defined as HP metric.
So what this means is that each
time our training code is run,
we'll have this model.fit,
it'll train the model,
and then, after the
model has been trained,
we're capturing what the
validation accuracy looked
like on the last epoch and we're
reporting that to Vertex AI
so that each time we run one
of these training trials,
we're able to see what the
validation accuracy was
and that will help us determine
which trial performed the best.
With that, we are ready to
go ahead and containerize
our code.
So I'm going to jump back
over to the terminal,
and from the root of our
Vertex codelab directory,
I will create a Docker file.
So we can see that Docker
file right over here.
And I'm going to paste in
the following commands.
And what this file
is doing here is
it's using, as the
base image over here
on line 1, the deep learning
container TensorFlow Enterprise
2.7 GPU Docker image.
These deep learning
containers on Google Cloud
come with many common machine
learning and data science
frameworks pre-installed.
And then, after
downloading that image,
we are going to pip install
the Cloud ML Hypertune library.
This is the library Hypertune
that we import in our script
so you just need to make sure
that you install this library
if you are using a base
image that doesn't already
come with this
library pre-installed
and then, in line 9, we're
copying over all this training
code to our Docker image,
and then in line 12,
we will set up the entry
point to invoke our trainer.
And all this means
is that it's going
to run our task.py file,
which is the file where we
had all of our training code.
So back in the terminal, we can
now go ahead and build and push
the container.
So the first thing
you'll need to do
is define a variable
for your project ID.
Now, I happen to know
what my project ID is.
However, if you
do not know, there
is a handy command that's
listed in the instructions
in the codelab.
The next thing we'll want
to do is define a variable
with the UI of the container
image in Google Container
Registry.
And this is where we
will push our image.
Container Registry is
the place in Google Cloud
where you can store any
of your Docker images.
The next command we'll
run is this gcloud auth
configure-docker,
which will just
help us to configure
usage of Docker.
And then we can go ahead
and build our image.
And this will take a
few minutes, probably
about five or so minutes,
the very first time
that you do this.
It's going to work a
little bit faster for me
because I have done this before.
But note that the first time
you do run this command,
it will take a
little bit of time.
OK, our image has
been built. And now
the next step is to push this
image to a container registry.
So we'll call docker push.
And again, this will
take a little bit of time
the very first time you do it.
I've done this before
so it was pretty fast.
All right, so the last step
before we go ahead and launch
the hyperparameter tuning job
is to create a Cloud Storage
bucket.
We will just need
a staging bucket
for when we launch
our training job.
So we can go ahead
and create our bucket.
So I've chosen to call the
bucket the name of my project
ID -hptune-bucket.
Buckets need to be unique.
So this is just an
easy way to make
sure we create a unique bucket.
And you can create the bucket
with the following command.
I'm not going to execute this
command because I've already
created this bucket.
But if you are
creating a new bucket,
this command will
help you do that.
And with that, we are
ready to head over
to step 7 and launch our
hyperparameter tuning job.
So the next thing we'll do is
go back and open the launcher
again one more time.
And I will create a
TensorFlow 2 notebook.
And in this notebook, the
first thing we need to do
is import the Vertex
AI Python SDK.
So we can import this SDK.
And then we will need to define
a couple of different specs.
The first spec that
we'll define is
called the worker
pull specs, and this
specifies the machine
type and the Docker
image for our training job.
So here we're specifying an
n1-standard-4 machine type,
we're specifying an Nvidia
Tesla V100 as our accelerator,
and we're going to
use two accelerators.
And again, this is so that
we have two GPUs so that we
can do distributed training.
Feel free to try out
different machine types,
different accelerator types,
use more or fewer accelerators.
The more accelerators you use,
of course, the more expensive
it will be, but feel
free to experiment
here however you like.
And the only thing you'll need
to change is in this image_uri,
you'll need to add in
your own project ID.
So there we have our
worker pool spec,
the next step is to
define the parameter spec.
And this is a dictionary
specifying the parameters
that we want to optimize.
So in this dictionary,
the keys are
going to be the strings that
we assign to the command line
argument for each hyperparameter
that we wanted to tune--
so recall, in our
get_args function earlier,
we defined these arguments--
learning rate, momentum,
and num_units.
And we're just making sure
we use the same strings so
that we're consistent.
And the value is going to be
a parameter specification.
And you can check out the
Vertex AI Python SDK docs
to learn a little bit more
about these different specs.
But at a high level,
hyperparameters
can be of type double, integer,
categorical, or discrete.
If you select the types
double or integer,
you'll need to provide a minimum
and maximum value as well
as a scale.
I linked, in the
codelab, a video that
helps you understand
a little bit more
about how to pick the best
scale in case you're curious.
And if you select
categorical or discrete,
you will need to provide
the actual values.
So in this example,
learning rate and momentum
are both going to be doubles.
And I've provided a minimum and
maximum value for each of them.
And I've set the
learning rate scale
to be log and the scale
for momentum to be linear.
And the number of units is
going to just be discrete.
So I went ahead and
set all of the values.
You can see them right here--
64, 128, and 512.
And that just means one of
these values will get picked
and the scale is,
of course, none
because we just are picking
from a discrete list.
So we can execute the cell.
And the last step is to
define the metric_spec.
So this is the last spec,
and this is the metric
that we want to optimize.
Again, we were optimizing
the validation accuracy
and we called that accuracy that
was the string that we defined
earlier as the
hyperparameter metric tag
that we set in our
training application code.
And the value here is going
to be the optimization
goal of that metric.
And that can either be
maximized or minimized.
Of course we want to
maximize accuracy,
but you might have use cases
where you're tracking a metric
that you want to minimize.
Maybe it's loss.
But in this case, we want
to maximize this metric.
That's defined all of
the specs that we need.
The next step is to
define the custom job.
This is the common
spec that will
be used to run the job on each
of the hyperparameter tuning
trials.
So that means that when
the hyperparameter tuning
job kicks off, multiple
custom jobs will be run.
This is taking in
the worker pool
spec which we defined earlier
where we specified our machine
as well as the Docker image
that has the training code.
So you'll need to make sure
that you update your bucket here
and that you put in the bucket
that we defined earlier.
This just needs to be some
staging bucket in your project.
So we'll define that here.
And then we can
execute the cell.
The next step is to create and
run our hyperparameter tuning
job.
So this hyperparameter tuning
job will pass in the custom job
that we defined earlier.
We'll also passed in the metric
spec and the parameter spec.
And then these last
three arguments
are specific to running
hyperparameter tuning jobs.
The first is the
max_trial_count.
You'll need to put an upper
bound on the number of trials
that the service will run.
And generally, more trials
will lead to better results,
but you will reach a point
of diminishing returns
after which
additional trials have
little or no effect
on the metric
that you're trying to optimize.
So generally, a best practice
is to start with a smaller
number of trials,
get a sense for how
impactful your chosen
hyperparameters are,
and then scale up as needed.
The second argument is
the parallel_trial_count.
And if you choose to
use parallel trials,
the service will provision
multiple training processing
clusters.
Increasing the number
of parallel trials
will reduce the amount
of time, overall,
that the hyperparameter
tuning job takes to run.
However, the downside is that
it can reduce the effectiveness
of the job overall.
And that's because the
default tuning strategy
will use results
of previous trials
to inform the assignments of
values in subsequent trials.
So we're defining
that tuning strategy
here in the search
algorithm argument, which
we've set to none.
And that's because, by
default, this default option
will apply a
Bayesian optimization
algorithm to search the space of
possible hyperparameter values.
This is the
recommended algorithm.
And I have linked to a
blog in the codelab which
has a little bit more
information on the mathematics
of how this works.
If you're curious, it's really
interesting so definitely
worth checking out.
So with that, we will launch
our hyperparameter tuning job.
So now that our
job has kicked off,
we can head back over to
the Google Cloud Console.
And we can head to the
Training tab right here.
And we can go to
hyperparameter tuning jobs
and we can see that the
job we just kicked off
is currently running.
So we can click on this job,
and we won't see a whole lot yet
because nothing's happened yet.
But we can see kind of the
start time, when it was created,
how long it's been running for.
We can check out the specs
that we defined, all here.
These are all the specs that
we defined in our notebook.
And then, eventually,
when the trials are run,
we'll be able to see
the results down here.
So this is going to take
about 30 or so minutes.
So I'm going to hop
back over and we'll just
take a look at a job that
I've run in the past that
has already completed.
And this will be
the same end result.
And this is what I
showed at the beginning.
So let's go ahead and see
all of the trials at once.
And we can go ahead and
sort these by accuracy.
So what happened
behind the scenes
is that our training
code that we defined
in that task.py file, it was
executed six different times
because we chose to run
six different trials.
Each of those trials tried
a different learning rate,
momentum, and number of units.
And you can see the
combinations that
were selected right over here.
And on the 10th epoch, which was
the final epoch of our training
job, we can see the
validation accuracy
score that was reported.
We of course want the trial
that led to the highest accuracy
score.
So that's trial ID 5.
And it had the following
learning rate momentum
and number of units.
So if 0.82 was a
good enough accuracy
score for our
particular use case,
we could go ahead and set these
hyperparameters to the values
here.
If we wanted to aim
for higher accuracy,
we could go ahead and run
even more trials since 6
is a pretty low number
and see if we can do
even better on this data set.
And one other last note is that
you can actually do all of this
through the UI.
So if we look back
over to Training,
you can click on this
Create button here
and you can actually
create a training job.
And under step 4 here,
you'll have the option
to set your hyperparameters.
So if you prefer to
do this through a UI
instead of doing this via the
SDK, that is also an option.
So that concludes the
workshop for today.
We saw how to use Vertex AI
for hyperparameter tuning
and distributed training.
We used a Vertex AI managed
workbench instance as well as
the Vertex AI Python SDK to
help us to launch and configure
this hyperparameter tuning job.
I hope this gives
you an idea of how
you can use Vertex
AI to help you
with model training and
faster experimentation
for your own machine
learning use cases.
And if you build something
cool with Vertex AI
and with notebooks,
definitely let me know.
Thanks so much for watching.
And I hope you get a
chance to run through
the codelab yourself.
[MUSIC PLAYING]